in 2010 a computer virus was discovered
in thousands of the control systems that
operate factories
power plants and nuclear reactors around
the world
this virus was 20 times more
sophisticated than any malware
ever recorded it could halt oil
pipelines
destroy water treatment plants and bring
down entire power grids
this virus was called stuxnet and we
should all be concerned
let's find out why
in january 2010 inspectors from the
international atomic energy agency
were visiting the natanz uranium
enrichment plant in iraq
they noticed that the centrifuges which
are used to enrich uranium gas
were tearing themselves apart one after
another hundreds of them
nobody could figure out why not the
inspectors not the iranian technicians
who worked on site
not even the engineers who built the
system meanwhile
a computer security firm in belarus got
a strange request from a client in iran
their machines were rebooting over and
over again even completely wiping the
hard drives and reinstalling the
operating systems didn't help
again the problem was a mystery but when
the technicians pulled apart the
operating systems
they found a new and very unusual virus
they called it stuxnet
and stuxnet was infecting computers all
over the world and spreading fast
now these events seemed unrelated at the
time
but they were very much connected cyber
security experts knew stuxnet wasn't
ordinary malware thrown together by some
basement hacker
the first clue was the size of the code
base most viruses are 10 maybe 20
kilobytes
stuxnet was 500 kilobytes and
uncompressed
it was 1.2 megabytes that's a pretty
large piece of code to go undetected
then analysts transferred stuxnet to a
new computer just to see what would
happen
now the test computer was not your
grandma's old compact laptop from 1997.
the machine was a state-of-the-art
highly protected workstation designed
for cyber security threat detection all
the bells and whistles
but as soon as the stuxnet files were
copied over the new computer was
immediately infected
without anybody doing anything and
without triggering a single alert
and that's very unusual when you install
software in your computer
it needs to be digitally signed with a
trusted certificate and the developer
supplies a certificate that your
computer checks against trusted
manufacturers
apple logitech whatever a lot of viruses
tamper with the signature
the certificate to try to trick your
operating system into allowing it to
install
now luckily virus protection usually
catches this
and you've probably seen that warning
when you're trying to install software
that's not from a trusted source
this catches a lot of nasties but
stuxnet didn't have
altered certificates it had valid
certificates
stolen from two trusted sources j micron
and real tech
now these companies make all kinds of
drivers for hard drives usb sticks
sound cards tons of stuff you probably
have their software on your computer
right now i definitely do
and when the creators of the stuxnet
worms signed their files with a stolen
cert
they wanted to make sure that windows
would install it very quietly
without any warning and if anyone
bothered to look at the cert they
wouldn't care because it was valid now
stealing a valid digital signature is
like trying to rob a bank vault that's
locked inside another bank vault the
security around them is
sci-fi spy movie level stuff they had to
physically steal the certificate from
inside these companies
that really doesn't happen but it
happened some more digging around
the code showed that as soon as stuxnet
infected a computer
it started probing the system looking
for flash drives usb sticks
and other storage devices and because of
the signing certificates
windows happily allowed it to do so what
security experts had discovered
is one of the rarest and most dangerous
kinds of software vulnerabilities and it
was at this time that they went from
curious and amazed to fearing for their
lives
look i'm not suicidal if i show up dead
on monday
you know it wasn't me what security
experts had discovered
is called a zero day exploit it's called
this because when a vulnerability is
unknown to the software developer
and microsoft and the anti-virus
community and the rest of the world
that means there are zero days of
protection against it nobody knows about
a zero day vulnerability
except the attacker exploiting it a zero
day is so rare and valuable
that you can actually sell it on the
dark net for hundreds of thousands of
dollars
not a good idea it's not think about
this
cyber security companies research over
12 million viruses a year
and in that time they might find maybe
or 12 zero day exploits it's a once in a
million occurrence
but stuxnet contained four zero day
exploits
this is unheard of it never happened
before and it hasn't happened since
eventually it was discovered that
stuxnet wasn't trying to steal passwords
or data it was actually targeting the
software on
siemens programmable logic controllers
called plc's
now plc's are small computers used in
factories and industry that control
pretty much everything assembly lines
water pumps power plants
and nuclear refining critical
infrastructure
runs on plc's if you can hack a plc
you can take down an entire country
without firing a single shot
now this had people very nervous because
industries all over the world were
reporting their plc's were
infected with stuxnet but it was just
sitting there nobody knew what it was
going to do
or when was the power grid just going to
turn off
was water or gas could it stop flowing
nobody knew
it felt like a ticking time bomb because
it was
even though the virus was spreading all
over the world to thousands of computers
per day
it was primarily targeting one country
iran
more specifically it was targeting the
iranian nuclear facility
in natanz that doesn't sound like an
accident
it wasn't a virus this complex and this
dangerous
requires millions of dollars to create
it takes time
the best programming talent in the world
and absolute secrecy
experts at first suspected and then they
were positive
that stuxnet could only have been
designed by a country
looking to [__] or wage war against
another country
this was a state-sponsored attack to
design and deploy a cyber weapon like
stuxnet
you need immense financial resources a
military intelligence infrastructure
and a motive to wreak havoc on an enemy
nation
do we know what country created it we do
but
they won't admit it so who made this
thing ah you're not gonna like it
no shh an intelligence agency
probably probably who has an interest in
uh setting back the iranian nuclear
program yes stuxnet was aggressive
but very quiet if stuxnet is on your
computer and you plug in a usb thumb
drive
boom the usb drive is immediately and
quietly infected
you don't have to run a program open a
web page or click anything you then plug
that usb drive into a different computer
on a different network
boom every machine on that network is
infected and this is exactly
what happened in iran the nuclear
centrifuges at natanz were air-gapped
meaning they weren't connected to any
outside network and this is usually a
good way to keep a network secure
the only way to infect a clean air gap
network
is user error yep user error
outside contractors who were brought in
to work on the iranian nuclear facility
in natanz
had also brought stuxnet in through
infected usb drives
and once stuxnet was in it deliberately
targeted the siemens plcs
which operated uranium enrichment
equipment so these plcs control the rate
of spin in the nuclear centrifuge
it's been too fast or too slow the
entire thing tears itself apart so
stuxnet got into the centrifuges
and then yeah and then what and then it
did nothing
it just looked around and kept logs of
everything happening in the equipment
but after 13 days stuxnet started
changing the speed of the centrifuges
every 15 minutes
sometimes faster sometimes slower
normally this is something a technician
would spot immediately but stuxnet was
using the data it collected earlier
to report back that everything was fine
but everything wasn't fine was it
it was not because stuxnet changes the
rate of spin every 50 minutes the
equipment weakens
and eventually tears itself apart
stuxxnet was also disrupting power feeds
causing centrifuges to explode and once
the equipment started to fail
there was no way to stop it even those
big red buttons you see on machines that
you hit in case of emergency
those were disabled too somehow stuxnet
thought of everything
not only was this virus created by
highly talented programmers
there was obviously input from experts
in nuclear enrichment technology
reactor operations safety protocols that
is a dangerous virus
over a thousand uranium centrifuges were
destroyed
by stuxnet this set iran's nuclear
enrichment program back months
maybe years why well
iran's nuclear ambitions must be stopped
they have to be stopped we all have to
stop it
now that's the one message i have for
you today thank you
in the early 2000s iran was ramping up
its nuclear energy and enrichment
program
this was in violation of international
agreements so a lot of the work was done
in secret
also a violation now iran argued that it
had a right to pursue nuclear energy
but u.s and israeli intelligence
agencies suspected iran of using its
civilian nuclear program
as cover for weapons development so the
u.s
imposed sanctions and all sorts of other
things to try to pressure iran to slow
down its nuclear program
and deal but even with stuxnet and other
setbacks
iran kept enriching uranium they said
that they needed nuclear power to
provide energy to the population
energy don't they make oil over there
look i'm just telling you what happened
i'm not taking side this isn't a
political channel fine fine go ahead so
every time iran agreed to suspend its
enrichment program
diplomatic talks would break down and
they would go back to work
then they would stop again and start
again and it went on like this for a
while
but then the cia received thousands of
pages of documents
indicating that iran was modifying the
nose cone of a missile
to carry a nuclear warhead oh no oh yes
then it was discovered that iran had
acquired and hidden from
inspectors blueprints for more advanced
centrifuge tech iran claimed that these
documents were forged
but later admitted that they had
secretly imported equipment from a
foreign source
now by this time israel was getting fed
up and
threatening military action now bombing
iranian nuclear facilities might have
been a short-term solution
but almost certainly would have led to
war in the region and perhaps globally
they not another war yep another war
so the us's intelligence community
including nsa cia
and the newly formed u.s cyber command
got to work on what they called
operation olympic games olympic games
was a campaign of cyber intrusion
disruption and sabotage of irani
wait the u.s government created stuxnet
what i i haven't give you enough clues
well i was just so enthralled with the
stories
i appreciate that now officially no
country has acknowledged developing
stuxnet
but through leaks at nsa and cia and
using common sense
it's generally believed that stuxnet was
developed by the united states with help
from
israel the uk and their allies dumb
question
go ahead when you destroy something with
a bomb or with a virus
isn't it the same thing well funny you
should ask that
it's a act of war please let's
be frank here okay
countries are constantly hacking each
other and spying on each other looking
for information
and most countries have agencies and
protocols to protect against this it's a
game of intelligence cat and mouse it's
been going on forever
but stuxnet was the first time a
nation-state developed
proactive offensive weaponized code
that could do actual physical damage to
another country
if a nuclear reactor could be destroyed
from the inside
what other real world damage could
stuxnet or other malicious code do
if you attack a power grid or a water
supply lots of people are gonna die
so iran felt like this was not a simple
covert act of espionage
but a blatant act of war committed by
the us and its allies
what did they do about it well what
would you do fight back
that's exactly what they did iran sent
out a virtual call to arms
and quickly built one of the largest
state sponsored hacker groups in the
world
they got to work they attacked saudi
aramco the largest oil company in the
world
and destroyed every computer they had
thirty thousand machines hard drives
were white
clean phone lines were down email
offline
it was a nightmare no no then they went
for america's financial infrastructure
and levied attacks against wells fargo
pnc
and bank of america taking down banking
systems all over the world
and there were other attacks now iran
didn't officially take credit for these
attacks but
then again they didn't really have to
the message was clear
come for us we'll come for you a plc
attacks did happen before stuxnet
viruses have destroyed power generators
dumped raw sewage on cities disrupted
railways
there was even an attack in the 90s
against worcester airport in
massachusetts that grounded flights for
a day
but those attacks were done by single
hackers and disgruntled employees
when you have the resources of an entire
country deployed for state-sponsored
attacks
the world becomes a much more dangerous
place but now that we know about it
we're safe from stuxnet right no
no for years cyber attacks on our nation
have been met with indecision and in
action
the internet has been a great equalizer
any information available online is
available to everyone
everywhere forever now you can't buy a
tank or a bomb online hello
darknet okay the dark net is different
and we have an episode coming up on that
so while you're waiting for it hit the
like and subscribe all the buttons but
don't try to buy a tank on the dark net
what you can find online
are plans and blueprints to make all
kinds of scary things
still if you try to put together some
doomsday device in your garage
you're going to raise some eyebrows i
mean my wife can't spray paint a flower
pot in the driveway without our nosy
neighbor coming over
i can only imagine what he'd do if i
started welding together pieces for an
emp
device that would make a good diy video
it would i'd watch that
but stuxnet isn't a thing it's it's
lines of code but it's lines of code
that can damage
actual property and hurt actual people
and the stuxnet code
it's just out there now if you know what
you're doing you can take the code apart
make a few changes and now you've got a
really sophisticated weapon
you can even do this if you don't know
what you're doing which is probably more
dangerous
now as we speak thousands of people
around the world
have the stuxnet code and they're
tinkering with it seeing what different
pieces can be used in their own attacks
there have already been a few viruses
inspired by its engineering the dooku
virus attacked industrial facilities in
flame in 2012 also attacked facilities
in iran
and flame could record audio skype calls
take screenshots
log keystrokes all kinds of stuff in
destroyer
attacked power facilities in ukraine in
2016.
and there's tons of others stuxnet is
the best cyber weapon the united states
has ever developed and it gave it to the
world
for free now for perspective natanz in
iran was a brand new nuclear facility
with an
gapped network and a team of security
professionals working around the clock
and it was taken down easily but a lot
of industrial control systems are not as
sophisticated
some are connected to the internet
without default passwords and many
systems crucial to a country's
infrastructure
are running software that's 30 even 40
years old not just at iran
here in the us in the uk everywhere
how vulnerable are those systems to
attack iran has already said that cyber
attacks
will be answered with cyber attacks and
i think we can assume that every country
in the world has this policy i mean it's
national defense
well remember how i said the internet is
a great equalizer
well think about this for a second
throughout world history
global powers maintain their status
through wealth
and military might but today you don't
need a trillion dollar defense budget in
order to impose your political will
on the world now all you need is a dozen
smart programmers and lots of mountain
dew
now that the world's richest and poorest
nations all
employ skilled hackers is cyber warfare
like the nuclear arms race
where mutually assured destruction means
that no country would dare attack
another
i mean surely no country would risk
retaliation by unleashing further chaos
on the world
right your sarcasm is palpable
[Music]
the link between the outage in
mumbai in october last year and the
suspected role of chinese hackers
chinese hackers backed by the chinese
state
targeted two indian vaccine makers
tonight as researchers raced to develop
a vaccine for the coronavirus hackers
from china and other countries
are working just as furiously to steal
that research
to create their own operation olympic
games gave us stuxnet
the most advanced and destructive cyber
weapon ever used when it was unleashed
on iran
it was an hiroshima moment and like
hiroshima
stuxnet was only the beginning a test
case for
more advanced more devastating cyber
weapons
and one of those weapons has already
been deployed that weapon is nitro zeus
yeah that sounds like the name of a
greek energy drink
you're really throwing ice water on my
drama here pal yeah i'm sorry i i make
jokes when i'm nervous
okay back to iran after coming pretty
close to war
cooler heads prevailed and iran along
with several world powers
signed a nuclear peace agreement that
was the ideal outcome
but that outcome wasn't always certain
so in case diplomacy failed and war
broke out the united states had
and has a cyber contingency plan the
plan
code name nitro zeus is a virus far more
complex than stuxnet
and was developed by thousands of people
at a cost of hundreds of millions of
dollars
nitro zeus or nz was designed to infect
iranian
infrastructure and await orders in case
of war
nz would disable iran's air defenses
disrupt
military command and control take down
parts of the power grid
it would attack domestic communications
transportation
banks financial systems now i don't have
to point out
that these aren't just military targets
millions of civilians
would be harmed if nitro zeus or a virus
like that
was used on anyone now according to
former intelligence operatives nitro
zeus has already been deployed
and is living in iranian infrastructure
right now just awaiting instructions
now that's pretty scary but what scares
me more about nitro zeus is
what happens when that code gets out
it's inevitable that more countries will
acquire the capacity to
use cyber both for espionage and for
destructive
activities you'll hear people say that
the next world war will be fought in
cyberspace
they're wrong about that the united
states iran
china the uk russia north korea
they're not preparing for cyber war
they're already fighting it
and i'm being completely honest now off
script
researching this episode was stressful
and i'm left with more questions than
answers
like how can citizens who are threatened
by cyber attacks
have an honest conversation about these
dangers when our
own governments don't acknowledge they
participate how can one country ask
another to disarm
when it won't disarm itself but the
biggest question of all
how can the global community ensure that
destructive cyber weapons like stuxnet
and nitro zeus don't fall into the wrong
hands
don't create them in the first place
that would be a good start
until there's a global effort to address
this threat all we can hope for is that
our governments can keep us safe
and hope our leaders can avoid another
international crisis
that's a lot to hope for the cyber war
is here
and now i find myself longing for the
days of the cold war
when a concrete wall ran through berlin
when proxy wars were
fought on every continent when global
superpowers had thousands of nuclear
weapons aimed at each other
just one decision away from armageddon i
long for those days
because back then the world was a much
safer place
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything today do me a favor
comment like subscribe
share do all that stuff the algorithm is
a she-wolf
with sharp claws and teeth but with your
help we can defeat her defeat
the she-wolf until next time be safe be
kind
and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
you